what are a couple of things that you've
learnt to do with this prime
factorization okay you've learnt like
this thing called the highest common
factor so for instance we know the prime
factorization of 24 okay let's do the
prime factorization of 100
okay now what was I asked to do I'm just
going to leave that I'm not I don't
trust my Amidon so who wants to give me
am some factors 50 by the way 250 you
could have picked what else could you be
okay now I actually think 10 and 10
might have been a better choice that
she's why like we said like I said if we
chose 2 and 12 or 4 and 6 & 8 & 3 we
will end up at the same spot and that's
what the important things the prime
factorization is unique there's not like
a whole bunch of different ones there's
only one okay but 10 and 10 would have
been better can anyone suggest to me why
okay so did you catch that so let me
repeat it because it's really important
and it will save you time is ten and ten
are a better choice because let me
actually write it let's change these
here if I make this ten at this temp
okay now once I do the point practice
for this I already know the prime
factors for this and I thought it twice
right so if I done it for ten right okay
what are the two factors to it right I
don't need to do any more mental work
right because I've already done it for
these two
whereas for two and fifty two and fifty
and have to think about fifty then I go
thinking about 25 or five or 10 or
whatever okay
whereas here I'm done I'm finished okay
so there for sure right I can say a
hundred is equal to two two squared 5
squared
good bigger okay so now I can say
alright what is the highest common
factor right and you remember I'm not
sure if you got sure shown there's a way
to write this right the highest common
factor are 24 and a hundred what's it
equal to how do we find it jasmine okay
so I've got my factor trees now there's
one I should have made them smaller but
there's this one and there's this one so
what do I do with them all right all
right here 24 is 2 cubed okay good now
what so I'm trying to look for see these
things are the factors right so I don't
want to look for the ones that are in
common okay so for instance the threes
in the fives not in common so we forget
about them okay I've got two twos here
and I've got three of them here right so
how many am I going to get that are in
common
2 so it's 2 squared which is 4
it's that makes sense
see that see what I did what am I
looking for I'm looking for the highest
common factor
what does Coleman mean was less usually
what has taught me it's important that's
exactly right there's a three here but
it's not here so it can't be coming
there are five CR but they also know in
climate so they can't be part of my
highest common factor right now I can't
pick three twos because I don't have
three here
there are three in common right there's
only two okay so that's why this is two
squared which is make sense yeah okay
hello everyone doing the lowest common
multiple how do I do this this is tricky
isn't it most common level of 24 and a
hundred how do I work it out yeah okay
so I got a circle all the ones that are
the same okay so so far I've just got
that two square that's the same yep okay
so if I cross to them out here let's
rehearse what we've done we've got the
twos in common I crossed that one the
two team
now why okay so I've got this three we
got the five square and I love the two
okay so I'm going to take the lot and
I'm going to multiply it or through so
let's write that okay so I've got 2
cubed times 3 times 5 Schmidt that's a
big number
isn't it can we work it out you got you
calculated there
we broke up
I'm guessing it's 600 is it is it yeah
by the way just in case you're curious
the way that I did it is I said well
this is 24 times 25 isn't it
24 times 25 when you let your times
tables I'm not sure how many of you
learn that 25 times 25 is 625 that's an
important one right so if I've got 24
and that's one less isn't it but if I've
listened that's how I got to 600 to pass